i had a one teacher in in the mba that
the course was
um you know think of a startup that you
want to start and that startup that i i
thought of during that course ended up
being my first company that i started
mobile advertising company
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel an immediate
partnership with ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i am with noam toyster ceo
and co-founder of bookaway.com a ground
and sea transportation platform
basically booking.com for travel
transportation the company has recently
raised the b round and acquired several
of its competitors in order to grow
during covid he started bocawei after a
bad travel experience in the philippines
during his honeymoon and the company is
now one of the leading travel
transportation companies in the world
nom toyster welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you
good how are you doing
thanks for having me
thank you very very much for joining me
i'm excited to talk to you today all
about travel and your own
your own personal journey which is very
uh non-trivial and non-linear uh some
people dream of becoming entrepreneurs
growing up i don't believe that was your
dream growing up uh perhaps it is
something that be that that you
facilitated more and more later on in
your in your career and your journey so
i'd love to hear a little bit about you
know your upbringing and and how you
find found yourself today
running a travel company before you were
in the mobile ad space
uh
and tell me a little bit about yourself
and then we'll dive deep into book away
where doing business was was you know
my consciousness even like my both my
parents were teachers and
none of my
brothers or anyone just you know went
into entrepreneurship
um and it kind of uh
fell onto me when i was in the
university i was working in sales and
when you work in sales you have to to to
kind of
are
kind of weird if you if you don't think
about you know how sales work and how
business works approaching people that
that never heard of you uh convincing
people to do stuff that they didn't
necessarily intend to do when they met
you
um and
and thinking about what is value
actually equation you know what's the
value for you as a seller what's the
value of a customer is a buyer and that
kind of pushed me into into the
marketing world the business world um i
was studying psychology in university
basically
i did what i wanted to do so i just went
to psychology because it sounded very
interesting and
and
and kind of uh you know deep
and while i was studying it i was
thinking that you know i was more and
more attracted towards the the
behavioral aspects of sales
um of business uh social psychology and
um
did not go that direction going being a
researcher in psychology is not
something i would do that
not not my type of thing but uh
it was very interesting for me and at
some point during
the first degree that i did
i actually decided i want to be a doctor
right so i want to help people and i
want to do something that that's very
meaningful in my life and that didn't
work out
so so i i finished my first degree i i
applied to med school and i
i passed a few interviews and then i i
didn't pass the last interview and
at that point i was sort of asking why i
was working in sales i was asking myself
what should i do with the next year of
my life so you're so you find yourself
doing an mba
and
what what is you know what about
entrepreneurship then draws you as
you're transitioning
you know pretty radically your
perception of what it is that you want
to be doing
to be honest i
i had
i don't ever told you but i had a one
teacher in in the nba that that the
course was um you know think of a
startup that you want to start and that
startup that i i thought of during that
course
ended up being my first company that i
started mobile advertising company and
and when the guy kind of talked about it
and we and we and we did dive into what
it actually means to start a company and
raising money and getting customers then
it it suddenly sounds you know it's not
rocket science right i could do that
um and and uh you know i looked around
me and i said i'm you know 20 something
28 whatever
i don't have any kids i don't have any
commitments you know if i if i'm going
to do this now is the time and and
that's how it all started
incredible okay so so take me all the
way to book away and we'll skip over the
mobile ads for now because there's so
much that i want to talk about
with with what you're doing with travel
you're backed by by some of the you know
best vcs
around particularly aleph from both the
series a and series b i believe and tell
me a little bit about you know the the
inception but also
you know what you've learned during the
process of building out book away
um so so where i started when i was
traveling in the philippines and i was
on my honeymoon and i was trying to get
a bus ticket to a very famous tourist
attraction and it was simply impossible
and and it wasted a whole day of my life
just trying to get the ticket and and
when i came back to israel i i started a
very very simple site with just a weak
side that sold those tickets and i had a
travel agent in the philippines that
went to the bus station bought the
ticket took a picture of it and sent it
by email to customers
incredible and that thing sold like
hundreds of dollars in a week or
something like that and and and i i
duplicated that model to a couple of
other countries just to see if it
actually works the same way in different
regions
and i realized it is the same in
different countries and and uh that's a
market that's a real market with a real
challenge and that's how always
why why is it why was it impossible for
you to purchase the ticket on your own
while you were there because it's just
not sold online um you have to go to the
bus terminal and getting to the bus
terminal if you if you've been to manila
is a two-hour taxi uh traffic and
everything so you take a taxi there you
buy the ticket you take a taxi back to
your hotel because there's never a
ticket on this for the same day
um
and that's after you know spending a
couple of hours actually figuring out
where the terminal is because nobody oh
my yeah nobody knows uh so so it's
ridiculous and and when you go to the
bus the bus is filled with tourists
they're they all did the same drill as
you
and and uh
and and that's when you know i had a
like a bulb
above my head yeah um but but the thing
that i learned i think it's not like a
wow moment it's uh you know because i've
i've had startups and and i've had
several ideas you know through the years
and i've tried many of them and what
i've learned is
that you have to try something in a very
simple way
um and if it works you see it if it
works it just works
uh and and it can't be
confused can't be you can't be mistaken
uh if something is working or not if
you're doing something and you're
looking at the at the numbers and you're
saying
you know that's okay
but you know i'm
not sure if that sold well or not then
it's not working it has to be something
that that if you're doing you know a
very simple proof of concept
you see the conversion and you see the
the effect on the customers you know
with the taking i guess and i i'm sure i
know that someone else said that can
remember who el who said that but
if anything that you're selling if
there's no one that is willing to pay
you uh something if you tell
even at the first time that he hears the
idea
and if there's no one that you can find
that will tell you i will pay for that
that's not a good idea and a lot of the
ideas that that people you know mess
around with is stuff that people say
that's cool that's cool that could work
they're not they don't say
i would pay you you know take my money
shut up sure exactly exactly tell me a
little bit more about how you did this
proof of concept because i think that's
just such a cool story of building a
wake up and then having somebody on the
ground
go and fulfill those orders
how on the proof of concept i just
contacted a local travel agent it
happened to be israeli so it was easier
but uh
in different countries i i contacted the
local travel agents and i just emailed
them i googled and i and i i looked into
tripadvisor forums and people say how do
you book the ticket from
hanoi to halong bay and then someone
says you know
that guy has the best vans in the city
go buy it from him and then i emailed
that guy and i told him listen i have
this side i want to send you customers
do you mind and he said and you know
most of them ignore you some of them
answer and say yeah sure well why not
and and uh
and it worked and you know we became
kind of very significant partners for
for a lot of our uh
our uh operators
take me a little bit fast forward to
today what what is the vision of book
away today you've raised your series b
and i believe 42 million dollars raised
so far what what is sort of the vision
of book away and where are you at today
with this division so so we raised 46 so
far series b was 35 million dollars uh
buko is basically going to be the
booking.com of transportation i want to
be the one place that
brings this very fragmented inventory
online and aggregates everything across
the board whether you want to book a bus
a ferry a train or even a private just a
private transfer a car with a driver uh
to take you when you're traveling abroad
uh also domestic travelers
we want to be the
go-to platform for that
and as you're thinking about the space
because obviously it's a pretty
congested space in terms of different
players that are playing there whether
you have transportation aggregators
or
or hospitality aggregators or review
sites
how how does book away fit into this
space now and and what what do you see
is the key differentiator there
so it's not a very
condensed space at the moment uh at all
you have uh specific
market leaders players in specific
regions so you have a company that's
leading uk market or or the europe made
market or companies leading the us
market and then you have very regional
uh competitors you have a company that's
you know the biggest company in vietnam
uh or the company that's the biggest
company in malaysia but you don't have
global players there you don't have a
booking.com or if you want to take it to
to the i guess activities industry if
you know that market a get your guide or
trip advisor of that market
uh there is no sort of gorilla in the
market yet and and there is room to be
one
um so so that market is going to be
consolidated and we are on track to be
that company that leads the market
and so if you're looking you know
obviously this past year travel has
decreased tremendously and
what did you have to do then as the
leader to adjust to this new reality
that you were confronted with over the
last year and a half
so it was a very hard time for for us to
book away because when we went coffee
started we were on on on really on track
we were doing x 3 year over year in
sales uh everything was going great
and and then coffee to hit and
you know at first we everyone thought
you know that's gone this thing is going
away in a couple of months nothing to
nothing to worry about
and
being in travel we we saw the impact
quite quickly we saw them the numbers
reduced by 20 30
in in february which was really early
and we decided to
to do what it takes to to survive that
time anyway we realized pretty soon that
it's not going to end
in a matter of uh six months and we
decided to
to reduce the our workforce basically we
had to let go of
almost half the company which was a
really hard moment uh for for book wow
um yeah and because everything's going
great and at that time by the way
it didn't seem not if most people didn't
get covet as a life-changing event for
for in the world uh
a lot of people at that point said this
is a right
um and and we let go of we won the first
companies african israel that let go of
a lot of employees
and
about
months later it was clear that we did we
did the right decision because
right our sales went down from you know
20 dropped to 99 drop
unbelievable and and at that time we
just decided to focus on the
infrastructure right focus on the basis
of our business getting more operators
onto the platform uh focusing on
creating more useful content getting seo
better and so on
and
and after about six or seven months
it was kind of clear that that it's not
even a six months uh
event it is a two three year event
and at that point we sat down and we had
just to to say okay so
we're not we can't what what are we
doing you can't sort of work on nothing
for three years because when you work as
a company and you want to see results
and there is no way to see results but
because there is no demand
right it's very frustrating for everyone
it's it's it's not it's not uh wait you
can't manage it really and we decided
either we it was a point where we said
either we're gonna go to hibernation
and you know
come back you know when make everything
as
lean as minim as as possible and and
come back when when sales recover
or we can take we can look around and
see if there's any opportunities
and knowing that all of our competitors
would be in the same situation
we decided to reach out to two different
competitors in the market and see
it started as how's it going you know
what are you doing you know let's see
you know everything is everything is
let's help each other
and
and it uh
it rolled into a a
round funding round in which we
basically
bought a couple of our competitors in
the market and and basically we turned
book away into a group of brands
that is now one of the biggest companies
uh in ground transportation globally
and we kind of managed to to convince a
lot of
other founders
that
by partnering we can get you can create
a much bigger company postcovid
and that that the partnering has a
a positive synergy synergy value that
will be able to work together and uh
and that it will create a better company
for them as well
and uh it's not trivial at all to
convince
different players in in different
regions in the market with different
cultures
to go and take that leap of faith
right and uh
and we've managed to do that
and we believe that postcode we're going
to be
you know on our track to being a you
know multi-billion dollar company
because we're going to be the leaders in
this market
incredible i love it and i love the
you know the thinking
you know as a leader i can only imagine
what it means to not just lay off have
the company but then also to have to
work
on a product with with very little
feedback from customers not really
seeing the traction and having to
sort of figure out how to navigate
through the situation but it sounds like
what you did is you just turned it
upside down
acquired a few of the direct competitors
and join forces for a book away group
and now they being one of the leading
brands
in in in booking travel and i think
that's something really really cool and
now i i'd love to take you back a little
bit
to to yourself
and understand you better
you know coming in with this
untraditional path what really sparked
your curiosity growing up what is it
what is something that you were really
fascinated by as you were growing up
okay i have to disappoint you on that
because i want to do a pilot when i grew
up
so i had i had the the every kid's
vision of uh dream of being a pilot uh
in the air force
and then and then uh you know at some
point i uh my eyes went kind of bad and
i had glasses
and and then you can't be a pilot and
that kind of changed my plans
uh um and uh
and as a kid i i i never kind of
dreamt of of uh of doing what i'm doing
now i just know that
as you know an employee in in you know
when i worked for people when i studied
i knew that
i want to do something that is very very
diverse i don't want to do something
that is
a very specific field i want to do
something that
you know changes
as i work
that gives me new challenges
every every once in a while
that makes me learn new things
and i knew that i get bored very quickly
from things anything that that i do for
like uh more than a certain amount of
time i i i get it and then i said
i know not interesting anymore
and you know running a startup
is perfect for that it you know in
hindsight that that's my you know that's
my perfect job i guess because
being a ceo of a company is
doing something diff completely
different more or less every six months
it's not
it's it's completely different skills
and different uh
and different uh you know
schedule and everything
i love it i love it and what are a few
words that you would use to describe
yourself
i guess i like the word uh
tenacious tenacious
um i think that kind of describes well
you know
my journey here because i guess you can
imagine that that uh
doing a travel startup
in israel which doesn't have too many
travel companies um selling to emerging
markets markets that are not
very
you know obvious due to investors in
israel that are used to the u.s market
the eu market maybe um
you get a lot of objections a lot of uh
of of uh
of no's and you have to keep at it and i
think that uh that is
what we're doing what i've done
um another thing that i i would like to
think about myself as as being very
honest and straightforward person
um i think that you know i'm very direct
and in what i want and and what i uh
believe in
uh probably to the point that that it
hurts me sometimes in front of
of of you know different stakeholders
um
but you know that's the way i am they
take it or leave it i i we've managed so
far to to partner with
investors that
that are great and and that are you know
appreciate that uh in in
in their founders
right
uh and uh i think that you know
that just following the journey and you
know the different lessons that you
learned
building at book away uh looking at you
know travel during covet and adapting to
it but and and doing all that without
coming from this entrepreneurial
original background and not having
living this is a live dream but it's
sort of this mission that you're on
and and obviously you're doing it for a
second time now very successfully and so
i think i think that's just an
incredible journey and i can't wait to
use the the them to use this myself and
i especially love
the proof of concept that you did and
how you took your own challenge through
the honeymoon and translated that into a
product which seems to have taken off
and find product market fit very quickly
leading you to to book away and so now
i'm really thank you for taking the time
to be here with me i really appreciate
it and stay safe and stay healthy and i
look forward to using the platform
[Music]
you